- [Interviewer] All right, Jimmy, Jimmy,
oh, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Jimmy] Well, I was born in Compton
but I was raised here in South Central.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family,
growing up you had both your parents?
- It was, I mean, yeah,
like in the beginning,
I guess you could say it because my mom,
when I was like three, she took me
and my other little sister
to Mexico and left us there
for a while till I was
like, probably like six.
I got to, like me and my mom, I guess and,
but she went to pick us
back, like pick us up
and bring us back to the US,
I guess she couldn't take
care of us at the moment
so, you know, she had to,
she did what she had to do.
Yeah, and my, like, she
wasn't, like, I've never
got to meet my real dad,
like, but that I had like
my stepdad, I guess you
could call him like,
that's pops, you know?
Like I love him, he's a good man.
You know, the other guy, I
don't know who the fuck it is.
Truth be told, I don't really care but...
- [Interviewer] Your real dad?
- Yeah, I don't know who's that,
but my parents were cool, you
know, it's just, I don't know,
I guess I'm the black sheep of the family.
(Jimmy chuckles)
- [Interviewer] But your
mom was in your life
most of your life?
- Yeah, my mom is super cool,
she's like, she's like
my best friend, you know?
Like, she's like my crime, like my crimee
I guess you could say, in a way she's done
some crazy things for me.
I'd be like, well, not just
any mother would do, you know?
Like stuff they could
get in trouble you know,
and dad has always been there
it's just that he
started fucking out like,
well, I'm the one who
got him into that shit,
you know, he just started messing up
and now they both live in
Mexico 'cause they got deported
'cause of me basically.
- [Interviewer] How
did they, what troubles
did they get into?
- Well, see my, like I started,
like I started gang-banging, right?
And I guess you could
say luckily I ended up
moving to a house where it
was like next to those parcel
and you know...
- [Interviewer] Okay, next to a what?
- It was next to a door spotlight.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
- Yeah, so I figured
like, hey, I could do that
and I just went and I
hung around with them
and next thing you know I'm
selling, I'm selling dope
and I'm selling crack and
it just started moving up
because the spot got raided.
They ended up fucking
taking most of the people in
and by some coincidence me and one homeboy
were left like untouched
because we weren't there
at the moment and all the
stash got left to us, you know,
so like we just started
blowing up from that point on.
And my dad, I made my
house until those spot
and I got my dad into drugs,
you know, like he was,
he used to be a little,
a little bit of cold
when he would drink like
any other Mexican and shit
but when I had a bunch
of it and he would ask me
for like a little bubble, I would be like,
here, just take this bunch
don't be asking me for more, you know,
and one thing led to another,
he started selling dope for me
and ended up going to prison for like,
I think it was like two
years, two, three years.
And he got out about two years ago
but I tried to, I tried to cross him back
and they caught him that
same week that he got out
so he ended up going back
for another two years
so he didn't, he don't wanna come back,
he don't wanna try it again, you know?
And, and we'll mom's,
she was gonna get her,
her papers done already too but it's like
when it was time for
me to show up in court,
by that time I was already smoking
like the whole (indistinct) like that
so I would just tell the
judge like fuck off or,
you know, like I don't care about this,
like to his face, just
go to sleep right there
when they're trying to ask me questions
and they denied her to her papers
and because of that she
had to take off to Mexico,
you know, yeah.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- Man, look from, look I've
always been a geek, a nerd,
like, I like educated myself.
I was an honor student all
the way to like eighth grade
when I graduated, still
as a honor student,
I went into high school and I like,
I started liking girls and, you know,
it's like girls they want
like kids with money or,
you know, kids that are popular
and me being a school boy
wasn't having that so I
figured, hey, I remember I took
a little, I bought a sack of
weed and I roll up a blunt
and I pulled up and I,
everybody wanna be cool.
So I'm like, all right, here's what to do.
I started smoking weed and
I started hanging around
with the wrong crowd and ha, here I am.
You know, it went like, from, like I went
from like a perfect, the perfect child,
like not perfect, I'm
talking about like in school
and stuff like that I was a good kid,
but when I hit high school, wow,
everything is like, I ended
up going to juvenile hall
for the first time and then
from that point on it was like
in and out of jail all the
way till recently, you know.
- [Interviewer] Then getting
your parents in trouble too?
- Yeah, like, but with
them it was something else.
It was like I started getting carried away
because of the money.
You know, there was so
much money coming in,
it's like, you know, my mom's mad I come,
here mama take this or here mama
look what I bought for you and the blue,
with a nice bracelet, you
know, she's happy again
and I get to sell dope again, you know,
but I wasn't thinking about all that shit,
I was just thinking more
like, let me get my money,
you know, and let me fool these bitches
and, you know, and that's it.
But, that shit turned
around and bit me in the ass
'cause a lot of shit happened
because of that, you know.
- [Interviewer] Did you ever get caught?
- Yeah, I got and that's the
first time I went to prison
after, after they got,
after the spot got raided
and it became my spot.
It was more like, like how long
can I last out here, you know?
Because we already had undercovers
looking for the rest of us
but we didn't care because we were,
we were smoked the fuck out.
You know, we were doped
up and truth be told
I really didn't care because
I got the house shut up,
I got the house ran into,
the house got raided,
man, all bad.
You know when I pull him
out when my house got raided
it's like, I was the
only one who got caught.
Me and some dude that was just passing by
but they got him on accident.
But I remember I saw my
mom and my dad pulling up
and my dad in the truck and
they just put it in reverse
and just took off acting
like they didn't see nothing
but I already knew what was gonna happen
if it ever came down to it.
But I was careless, you know,
like when you're fucking drugged
up, you don't give a fuck.
- [Interviewer] What type
of drugs were you selling?
- Man, I'm telling you, oh,
it's 'cause I got too carried away.
We started, I would, we had cold,
cocaine was the main
thing but out of cocaine
you're making crack, your
making cocaine, right?
Then we started selling meth
which we already have meth any fucking way
but you know a lot of
us smoke it so it's like
it's hard to smoke and then
sell it at the same time
unless you're selling in quantities.
And then what I figured, like
we should do it like this
and it's like, I didn't wanna stop there,
I wanted to get bigger, you know?
So, I started buying
stolen RAM for example,
I started sending crackers
out right here downtown
to do a little missions
to get jewelry for me,
pay them with crack,
you know, fucking them,
I had some, I had some girls.
I ain't gonna say they get
out there hauling there
'cause they're, they're
not, it's more like here,
I'm gonna take you to this club,
get them all for the drunk,
pull 'em up and we're gonna come up, okay?
And you know, and just come
up for whatever you got.
- [Interviewer] You'd rob them?
- Like, I'm not gonna say
rob them, you know like...
- [Interviewer] You
got (indistinct) trick?
- Like we not, like kind of yeah,
but we would only just
trick them into like going
somewhere where they're
by themselves, you know,
and from that point on,
basically look, I'm being honest.
My homegirl used to like drag them up
with some Chico G, you know,
I don't know if you've heard
of that shit but it's liquid.
It's like, it's like, I
don't know what it used to be
to be honest with you and
I know that you drink,
I'm gonna say a cup full like this,
like a two liter soda cup full, a full one
and you're passing out, drunk, gone.
You know, it's supposed to be something
to help your muscles heal after a workout,
but people started fucking around with it,
you know, in a different way.
It's cool though, like
if you drink it like,
like at a pace, like it's
cool, it's a shit, it's a shit.
But if you drink too much
of it, I swear to God
you'll pass the fuck out and
it's happened to me before,
you know, to where you
wake up and you're like,
what the fuck?
Where's my money?
I want my stuff like,
and you are with a hooray
you don't even fucking know yesterday
and you know, and she came
up and that was her shit.
- [Interviewer] So how much
prison time have you done?
- Like, I've done two terms;
one was 24 months with a half
but I ended up doing
like 18 months overall
but because I went to
the SHU, I did a SHU term
and then the second...
- [Interviewer] What is a SHU term?
- It's is like, it's like
jail inside jail, you know?
Like...
- [Interviewer] Why is
it called SHU program?
- The SHU program is like
long-term, it's not like,
it's not like, like in the
county you go to the hall
you go to the hall and
they put you inside a cell
where you don't see TV
or talk to other people
for a while like, I don't know,
I've been to a hall as well
so I, like I was there for
like 30 days, 30, 40 days.
You know, the SHU is more
like when you're doing time
in the SHU, like literally
like and locked away
from everybody not, you'll
never get to touch somebody else
or talk to somebody
else directly, you know?
And I did the SHU term, I
got to prison that same day,
the next day they put me in
a cell with this one dude
who didn't wanna show his
paperwork to nobody, right?
And I'm like what the fuck?
This is my first time in
prison but even I know
that you're supposed
to show your paperwork.
You know, that's how people
know who the fuck you are
and what you in there for.
So he didn't want it to, I
talked to the people right there
and they're like, you know what?
This was a JK, he's stupid,
he's like Cucolo, no listen,
but I was just curious,
you know 'cause he had,
there was another, another
sally of his who was there
and this would fuck them up and he said
that he was in there for
rape, so now you got somebody
in there for rape but
you don't wanna ask them
for the paperwork?
Makes no sense.
So I just kind of started
talking with this guy, you know,
like trying to get cool with him.
Luckily, he knew my homeboy Coco so Coco,
he like, I don't know how many Coco,
we started talking, right?
And I just started like kinda
asking him low key like,
so what you're in here for?
So how long and you know?
Making a conversation.
Then he told me, oh yeah, I
raped this fucking fugget.
He's like, I raped the fucking fugget
because he was shaking his ass everywhere,
he wanted to give it to me
but he didn't at the end
but I still took that, call the cops.
He was doing 12 years,
also from the UTK Maywood.
Therefore, he's a fugget, anyway.
Yeah, so I went in, so the
main Dulay dude, you know,
this was in here for rape, he just told me
how fucking you gonna have him here
even I know you're supposed
to clean that shit up.
He's like, don't worry
we're gonna take care of it.
Long story short, he sends
me a kite saying, hey fool,
you know, you gotta take care of this guy
because he's your sally,
he's your responsibility
and you won't do it with somebody else.
And yeah, I was like, what the fuck?
I thought I was just gonna
take flight on this guy
but now they're like, now
you've gotta clean the yard
and I fuck it, it is what it
is, I ain't got no choice.
And we did that same day in chow, in lunch
and dinner actually, in the
yard, they had me meet up
with another guy, Chuckie from Watts.
That fool, he was good,
he's a solid homey.
He told me, you know what?
I'm a guy too, don't trip.
He just hands me on a blade,
you know, like what the fuck?
I was nervous as fuck
for real, like nervous.
So we started walking and
in the middle of the yard,
like , 'cause we had to cross the yard
to get to the fucking, to the lunch area,
I just see Chuckie step to the side
and this guy kept walking, just looking
and he looks to that side and boom,
he gets hit in the neck boom!
When he started falling
back, when he fell back,
boom, boom, twice, and then I don't know
what the fuck happens,
somebody snatched that shit
away from me and a bunch of
dudes started fucking up forward
and it's like, is the cleanup
crew was there you know?
That shit was crazy.
Like everything is like on point.
I didn't even know I had the blade,
I didn't even know where
the fuck the blade went.
All I know was I was getting
amazed with the super soaker
and getting punched with
beanbags and shit like that.
But yeah, I ended up
going to the SHU and from,
I was supposed to do like 12, 13 months,
I ended up doing 16
months, like 15, 16 months
and paroled out the SHU.
- [Interviewer] That's
what you get for murder?
- I don't know, I was in there for murder.
Oh no, no, here's the gist.
That's crazy, now that
you talk about it look,
so not the homie Chuckie like,
hey, if you don't say shit
all right, he starts putting
me up on games and I'm like,
all right, when we went to court
'cause they picked the case, right?
We went to court, I swear
on everything I love
that this mother fucker
put, they bring him
and this was right there like,
he pulls up and they're like,
can you point at the people who did this?
And he's like, looks at
me and looks at him like,
nah, it wasn't them.
And they're like, what do you
mean I was in there, like?
I don't know who the fuck it
was, it was a lot of people
beating me up, but he was
stabbed though he was stabbed
at the right here, right here,
he had his fucking hand
off fucking the bandage,
like I was scared as fuck though
'cause they were like, they were talking
about attempted murder or murder, but nah,
and he didn't even snitch
but he still pissy it up
so he's still a PC, you know?
But he didn't fucking snitch and I mean,
whether he raped that
fugget or not, I mean,
I gotta get to him, you
know, 'cause anybody else
would have been a hell
yeah, it was him, get him.
- [Interviewer] So, so you,
interesting story, did you..?
- For real.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, so you
joined the gang at what age?
- For like at 14, 14, 15, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And that's
what it kind of opened
the door for the drugs?
- Yeah but, kind of, yeah that was it.
Basically, it was the,
the females are like,
I like man, I like females, you know?
Like that's my thing.
- [Interviewer] So, so
you're down in South Central
to figure out what street runs right
through the heart of it?
Lots of girls down there?
- Oh yeah.
- [Interviewer] That are doing business?
You'll, you'll pick up
some of the girls, sometimes?
- Well look, no, I have,
I ain't gonna lie.
I have, because let's be realistic
they be some bad ass,
bad shits and you know
like for real, for real.
And I don't care what guy
fucking says, they don't,
they don't do that shit believe me.
They had the money, they'd come across it
and the opportunity just happened,
what happened right then and
there it'll go through but,
hell yeah, but see, females
and figure will all be having
a fucked up past attitude and they all,
look, even though my brain
tells me they just want,
they just wanna come up, dude.
They just gonna come up on your money,
it'd be like my dick telling me something,
I was like man, let's just go get it.
Let's just get it one time.
But see I be fucking luck 'cause
I was smoking meth, right?
So, I'ma fuck a bitch trying
to fuck for like a long time
and these females they have
in that shit, you know,
so it'd be like hard to be
like, hey, you don't fuck now
or like, what's up, let's
kick it the whole night.
It'd be rare when they
be like, yeah, you know,
but most of the time they be like, nah,
like right now there's this
much, I'd be like fuck.
Again, I've done it but it sucks you know,
'cause let's be, like,
I'm a man, you know,
and I guess what pushes me is knowing
I'm fucking a new person,
you know, every so often.
So, when they pull up and then
I'm about to fuck this female
but it's different than
me hanging out with her
and chilling and drinking and smoking,
doing whatever fucking drugs
we want to picking up a gun,
you know, I'm faking and be like come on
and shit just gonna happen
and spread her legs up
and go for it like,
bitch I ain't even ready,
what the fuck, you get me?
But, yeah, I don't know,
look, truth be told.
I don't know why the
hell I do it, but I do.
And you know what?
Look, I bullshit to not, most of the time
I don't even get my nut, why?
Because I be smoking shit, you know,
I'll be smoking meth so...
- [Interviewer] What does meth do to you
in terms of your sexual behavior?
- Yeah, like right now I'm already used
to that shit you know, I'm
hyper active as it is but,
like in the beginning that
shit was fucking, I dunno,
it turns you like, like a
money act like a maniac.
Like, I don't know if it's
the same thing for girls
but as guys, at least me, I'll get around
just quick, you know?
And, but like not arouse
more like a fucking horn dog,
like horny, like you
know, on some way our shit
like forget a Viagra
pill or an ecstasy pill.
Nah, that shit will have you
thinking like way out shit,
shit don't even go in your head.
Like you already mind
fuck this girls so much,
so many different ways then when it's time
for the real thing,
it's like what the fuck?
Now what it seems, you know?
It's crazy to explain it but...
- [Interviewer] You've been
using meth for how long?
- For, since I was like 14, 15.
- [Interviewer] So you're, you're regular,
you're an addict then?
- Yeah, I get it, I'm an addict.
Yeah, I mean it...
- [Interviewer] It's a
really popular drug now.
- It is, it is but, but
it's not what it used to be,
like, shit right now is fucking cut,
it's like, it's rare to find
some good shit, you know,
'cause they always are the chemicals they,
they're adding to it.
You see back then it was
like when speed Berlin
came out for example and
then it was, it was a glass,
then you know it became crystal
and all these fucking names
for it but in the beginning
it used to be the shit
like for real, that
shit gets you hyped up.
Not giving a fuck about
nothing, about nothing
but getting your nut,
or at least that was me.
Like that shit would turn
me crazy like, oh man,
I gotta go find me a bitch
so I could fuck, you know,
but it was like on the
websites, websites or, you know,
but when I'm, I wanna, I won't lie
it's been tough where
I just started walking
and I'm walking but through
the whole stall, you know,
where the bitches be and
just looking like which one,
you know, don't get me wrong
a lot of them be throwing it at me
but it'd be like I'm picky
'cause it don't be about
how good they look for me, it'd be like,
bitch you do this drug?
They use this drug 'cause if you do
then we're in the same boat.
- [Interviewer] So you want
somebody to do the drug
with you and?
- Hell, yeah.
- [ Interviewer] And go party?
- Exactly, I party and play.
You know, but it's rare to
find those and when you do,
it'd be like, man, you can't
trust this bitch for shit
'cause you know, she's drug addict, one,
you fall asleep, that's
it, your shit is gone.
You know, especially if it's fucking
little cracking but, yeah.
- [Interviewer] So do you have children?
- I got two boys.
I had a baby girl, she passed away
when she was three months.
Her name, look trip, her real
name was Baby Felony Perez.
That was her birth name.
Yeah, she passed when
she was three months.
Then
(clears throat)
I ended up doing some shit
that made me, you know,
flee the country to Mexico.
I was over there working like an illegal
'cause I didn't have Mexico
papers for five years
but I had another baby.
I had another two boys
with the same baby mama
and, and even though I'd be
like, I fucking these holes
and spending money here
and there or on drugs
or shit like that, like I
consider myself a good dad,
you know, I'm always there for my kids.
Like I just got here
last night around 4:00 AM
from Delano, you know,
they live all the way
the fuck out there.
I'm in South Central,
that's two hours away.
I got a car, I just got a general
like two, three months ago, you know?
And yeah, but I love them
and they love me like crazy
because my dad was cool to me so,
because of him I'm cool
with my kids, you know?
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Even though my dad...
- [Interviewer] Are you working?
- Yeah, I mean, no, and
have an, unemployment
takes care of me right
now, A D D, you know,
with the pandemic is like
shit, they're paying,
paying me basically what
I was winning, you know?
So, I'm not working but I
do work though, I do work,
I do work as a contractor and sales.
My thing is sales you know, like anything
that has to do with sales.
- [Interviewer] And the
crystal meth doesn't get
in the way of your, your work.
- Yeah, it does.
I ain't gonna lie, it does in the sense
that in the nighttime I'm up
and I'm trying to fall asleep
until three, four in the morning.
When, when I was working it's
like I gotta get up at seven,
six 30 'cause I work
in Culver city from LA
to over there with the traffic
it gets packed, you know, so
(Jimmy gulps)
down that, see, like I don't
smoke the fuck out right now
so I completely forgot what
the fuck I was talking about.
That's crazy.
(Jimmy laughs)
- [Interviewer] So you must
have some crazy stories
about the girls on Figaro
and doing crystal meth?
Have you ever been robbed before?
- Have I been robbed before a fe...?
Hell, yeah, look, oh, shit.
Not robbed though it wasn't,
I ain't gonna say rob,
like give me your shit.
- [Interviewer] Got it yeah,
but just stuff disappears.
- Oh yeah, like that,
like I told you that G,
that G ain't no joke,
look, don't get me wrong.
You fuck on that G and then
you do it the right amount
and fuck, dude it's like,
you gonna have the time
of your life, I don't
care what the female says,
she don't do she gonna it willingly
like for real, like willingly.
Just don't care too much,
she gonna pass the fuck out
and she ain't gonna do shit, you know?
And when I say pass out
I don't mean just like,
like just slowly go to sleep.
No, I'm talking about, you're
up and the next thing you know
boom, floor, fucked
up, sleep, knocked out.
So the next day blacked
out completely, look,
oh man, it's crazy.
Well, let me tell you about that one time.
So I, my homegirl telling
me, hey fool come through,
you know I got this bitch
wants to meet you, blah, blah.
When I get there, it turns out
that I went to high
school with her, right?
So, so we kicked her out
and I was like, should I?
But hey, well let's, we'll
kick it around and well look,
they let you babysitting this kid,
what the fuck are you gonna do?
Are you gonna kick it and
you're gonna stay right here.
She like, fuck that, I'm
gonna leave him right here.
She gave him five bucks, we gone,
I took that to mama, you know?
And the mama were right
there fucking smoking dope
and you know, we're right there talking
and you could tell this bitch wants dick
'cause she's telling me
she like, like, you know,
I could take dick like, the fuck,
you don't say that shit
out the blue, you know,
like you crazy as fuck but all right.
Anyway, I told her, hey, I got this G
and she's like, well
fucking, let's fuck around.
I took some and she took some
but I hadn't gone to sleep
for like, I don't know, I'm
gonna say two, three days
so you could only imagine
taking some of that,
it's meant to knock you out.
Anyway, I was already like this, you know,
I shut my eyes and when I
opened them she was gone
and I had dope, I have
money, my cell phones, man,
I had my money like, oh man, anyway,
everything was there except
the cash, except the cash.
She took off with that,
she took out like 650 bucks
which ain't really much but
shoot, that shit helps you know.
That shit, that's a
mama for like two nights
to harass, you know?
But yeah, she thought
I wasn't gonna find her
but you know, social media, Facebook,
that shit helps out a lot.
So I just punched her number,
her shit pop out like,
oh man, I started seeing
when she was live,
I mean when she wasn't,
when she was live, I'm like,
I was ready around her
area like, I'ma catch you.
She went live, oh, I know where she at.
Well, pull out bitch where's my money at?
She's like, oh shit, but I was
cool with her boyfriend even,
well, I guess I wasn't that
cool 'cause I was fucking her
while that nigga was in jail so, but yeah,
she ends up like, I'ma
pay you, I promise you,
I promise you.
I ended up just, you
know, she paid me probably
like a hundred bucks out of that.
The rest, nah, she was just,
she was trying to fuck out too,
you know, she was on a goal.
- [Interviewer] So, what do you see
for the future of your life?
You're, you're you're using
meth, not likely to stop,
where do you see your
life going from here?
- Far, look, it's crazy
you asked me that shit
because right now I'm in the
predicament where it's like,
I'm up in the air.
Like when I told you I came from Delano,
look, this time I got out,
I was supposed to fix shit
with baby mama, but I didn't.
I got out and I went
straight into fucking around
with meth and I fucked
that up so now it's like,
I come to LA because I live in LA
where right now I really
don't have a place.
To be honest with you, I
just been renting hotels
after hotel and the money I do get
and I've been coming up, you
know, like, I like to hustle,
I like to make my money
but when I get it, look,
bullshit should, I
don't know what the fuck
would be about these holes that I,
and then I'm not satisfied it's
like, okay, I got me a hole,
I got a room, we got drugs,
we got all this shit,
we gonna fuck, we got the porn going,
all this bullshit, right?
And then it's like, I'm fucking her
and I haven't even bust my nut.
When I'm like stopping making an excuse,
throwing on my clothes slowly,
walking her to the store
and then walking away from her
looking for the next one, you know?
Like, and I guess it
just be me or I dunno,
I dunno what the fuck but
now I got the next one
and while I'm in the
room, I got another one
texting me already or I'm over here
to find another one over here.
It's like, and then the shit about it,
it is like, I gonna fuck five,
six holes this fucking today.
The money gone, the drugs are gone
and I still haven't busted my nut.
Like what the fuck?
You know, that's that kind of
shit and I'm not like, look,
I ain't nothing wrong
with masturbating and shit
but me personally I don't do it.
I like to get my nut, you get me?
And when you get it like that naturally
like with a female, you
know, doing what the fuck
you like to do is like, it's
a better feeling, you know?
Like, come on, but don't get me wrong,
I checked out before like,
who has it, you know,
but it's not my thing so
that's why I get fucked up
because I got to pick up tight, you know,
different females do different things
and that's a shit, you know.
My life is fucked up like
for real, like, look,
don't get me wrong, I,
it was a point in my life
where I said, I was in prison actually,
I was in the SHU, I was
waiting for a letter.
Everybody kept getting
letters, everybody like,
everybody getting the little letter.
What about me?
I didn't get shit so I was mad.
So the next day I was
yelling at the door, like,
my girl rides with me, can
I get a fuck that bitch?
And you hear the homie like,
fuck that bitch, you know,
from their cells.
So, this, the librarian comes
and she's like look, look,
stop stressing here,
read this and you know,
it might help you and she walks away.
She gives me a paper with a sane saying,
worthy is a man who expects nothing
for he shall never be disappointed.
You know, so ever since then,
I figured like, you know what,
for real I shouldn't
expect shit from nobody.
That way I'm never disappointed.
Anything that does come up is
like, it's profit basically.
So yeah, I started doing that
and I started telling myself
like, any fucking mission
I could do to make money
whether it's dirty money,
good money, clean money,
however you wanna call it is green
at the end of the day, you know?
I'm like, I'm gonna do
it, I'm gonna go for it
whether I do it right,
whether I do it wrong,
whether it comes out good,
positive, negative, fuck!
Believe me I've done some fucking missions
that just fucked me up like right here,
fucking in Mexico, fucking with cartels,
like some way out deep
shit and, then I done
some stupid shit that just got me paid.
You know, like, like
I, like, I don't know,
like I found that, like I find this car,
it got the fucking trunk open,
fuck, is the trunk open?
I'm just curious, I open it, boom!
What happen is I find 20
bans, 20 G's right there
like what the fuck?
Like, I'm gone, I was gone,
missing MIA straight to TJ.
I was living the life
for like about a week,
a lot of gambling, but mostly bitches.
You know, like for real,
out there it's cheaper too.
- [Interviewer] You get to
diseases doing this stuff?
(Jimmy exclaims)
- Why you gotta ask me
some shit like that,
putting me all black look?
Fucking this time but look,
I'm clean though, look.
This time I went to fucking,
this last time actually
I'm in there and they're like,
they're testing me right?
Because I got psoriasis, I
guess I had stress too much,
you know, like taking a
test and they're like,
hey, you know, you got, you
know how they pull you a shot
and it's supposed to be
like a little bubble TB?
Some shit like that?
Yeah, I'm like, they're
like, you've tested positive
for that shit, I'm like what the fuck?
For real?
- [Interviewer] For what?
- For that TB thing, I
don't know what the fuck...
- [Interviewer] Tuberculosis.
- Ugh, is it?
It's supposed to be like a little bubble,
I don't know but they said that
it was because I was fucking
the wrong, wrong females
or some shit like that, you know?
And anyway, they gave
me a pill for what like,
oh no, they actually, it was a shot.
It was a shot once a week for three weeks.
And that shit hurt, that shit hurt,
I never took shots like that in my life.
I think it was, it was
penicillin and something else.
That shit hurt, so painful,
like, oh and that hurts
for like the whole fucking week.
You know, it don't hurt for just,
it hurts when that shit's going in
and then you're numb for like
the next three to four days.
You can't even sleep on that side.
We have, never again, condoms all the way.
(Jimmy mumbles)
- [Interviewer] All right
Jimmy, thank you so much
for sharing your story
man, I appreciate it.